hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
welcome to the first episode of 2021
brand new year
hope that it holds some good things for
you
me the rest of the world the whole bit
so there's a play by george bernard shaw
caesar and cleopatra and in there caesar
has a line that is
pardon him theoditus he is a barbarian
and thinks that the customs of his tribe
and island are the laws of nature
in this case caesar was talking about
his secretary brittanus who was of
course of britain
but i think that the lesson is a little
bit wider than that i think that we
all tend to think that the customs of
our tribe and island are laws of nature
the ways that we behave the ways that we
think the ways that we feel
what we think are right and wrong we
grow up in a certain environment
we tend to think that's the right way to
do it some of us rebel against it
others don't but it takes a lot of
thinking a lot of reflection to say you
know
it could be really really different and
i think that's an easy thing to say
about
customs right you know which hand you
hold the fork with when you eat or
something like that
maybe even about morality depending on
your issues about morality
but what about more objective things
like our psychology
how we actually think what actually goes
on in our brains
today's guest is joseph henrik and he
has argued that modern views of
psychology have been drastically shaped
by the fact that most psychological
studies most research work in this field
has been done by and on a very
particular subset of people
what he calls weird that's an acronym
not just that they're weird but i think
that's supposed to be the resonance of
it
it's an acronym standing for western
educated
industrialized rich and democratic the
point being that not only are most
psychologists in sort of western
universities where these characteristics
would be common
but most psychological studies are done
on college students at those
universities right
if any of you have been to college and
taken a psychology course like i say at
the beginning of the podcast
you might have participated in these
studies and guess what
it turns out that western educated
industrialized rich democratic
college students are not a
representative sample of
all of humanity and so joe henrich's
point is not just that we're looking at
a very specific subset
but that it is a weird subset he makes a
very persuasive case
that weird people are not just a subset
of all humanity but they are
outliers psychologically in fact even
sort of
at a anatomical level in terms of what
is going on
in the brain he argues that people in
the
weird sphere have sort of repurposed
their left
brain hemisphere for language whereas a
lot of other cultures the left
hemisphere is used more for facial
recognition
and of course this is going to have a
very important impact on
what you take the truths of psychology
to be
things that are habits or customs of
your people
you might take to be laws of nature and
in the best mindscape tradition joe
actually has a very interdisciplinary
background his undergraduate degrees are
in anthropology
and aerospace engineering he worked as
an engineer for a while in fact
before returning for his phd in
anthropology he later became a professor
both in psychology and in economics and
is now a professor
of human evolutionary biology at harvard
so he has a lot of different subfields
covered there
and what he's doing these days is moving
his research on from the simple
fact that weird people are weird to
asking how they became that way
and that's the subject of his new book
called the weirdest people
in the world how the west became
psychologically peculiar and
particularly
prosperous now he has a very very
specific
and sort of outlandish theory about how
this
happened and we'll talk about it in the
podcast very very roughly very very
simplified his idea
is that in europe the christian church
forbid marriages within families that
you know worldwide it was very very
common for people to marry their cousins
if not their brothers and sisters but at
least you know
close people within their families at
the cousin level
and he thinks that the church forbidding
cousin marriage encouraged association
between people who are outside your
family pro-social behavior where you
were sort of
forced to make common cause with people
who are not your family members because
you wanted to marry them or you know
they would be your in-laws
and that led to guilds and certain ways
of
working and associating and the economy
took off this is a very specific idea we
talk about it you may or may not believe
it
he summons a lot of evidence for it so
it's absolutely worth
taking seriously it's worth you know
comparing to what we talked about with
david savage where we talked about the
history of democracy and how it took off
in europe in a way
that was earlier than in other places so
the point of all this discussion in my
mind
is not to say that certain ways of
thinking and being
are right and wrong it's just to say
that there are
certain ways of thinking and being and
to not take those ways
just because they're part of your own
culture as laws of nature to be a little
bit more
open-minded reflective recognizing that
the ways we are
might be specific might not be perfectly
general it's a good attitude to keep in
mind
as we approach the new year so with that
let's go
joe henrik welcome to the mindscape
podcast good to be with you sean
so i was an undergraduate taking a
psychology course
uh some number of years ago we won't say
how many
and i remember that one of the
requirements for the course was that we
act as test subjects for one of the
psychology professors experiments
right and it slowly dawned on me like
are most psychology results coming from
testing
undergraduate students that seems like a
very non-representative part of the
world
uh but so you've really dug into that
and made that realization
uh a lot more quantitatively established
yeah so it turns out that that
requirement the kind of undergraduate
intro
psych where you have to be a lab rat for
the psychologists uh
existed for decades so until until about
2010
over 90 of all psychological studies
were done with university undergraduates
in the us
or europe canada places like that and we
raised the alarm about this in a 2010
paper called the weirdest people in the
world
others had raised the alarm prior to
this but we really underlined it because
there'd been enough data
done in diverse societies to show that
not only were undergraduates
uh one population among many unusual but
they
often when seen in a global perspective
anchor the extreme ends of the
distribution so we dubbed them weird
people where weird stands for western
educated
industrialized rich and democratic just
to kind of mark off and raise people's
consciousness
about the unusualness of their subjects
now since then people
moved away from using undergraduates but
now it's mostly online subjects from the
us
okay so i'm not sure if that's better or
worse
polling errors are on our minds these
days but um
i so just to be super clear here i did a
podcast just a few months
ago with olga hassan uh about growing up
weird but she meant weird in the old
fashioned sense like a different than
the people around you you
you have a very specific meaning of this
wonderful acronym weird
yeah and it's like i said it's just been
to raise consciousness that the
subjects most commonly used by
psychology for decades and also other
experimental disciplines like behavioral
economics are
just one population among many and also
psychologically distinct like
extreme in many measures that people are
interested in
so a lot of the psychology textbooks
that you would have had in your intro
class
are really a kind of cultural psychology
it's telling you about the psychology of
the population studied by the
psychologist but
it shouldn't be readily generalized to
the species yeah you know i want to
um be
understanding to the psychologists
because they've had a hard time recently
you know with replication crises and
and so forth and you know so i want to
emphasize that as much as we want to
say that it it needs to be better uh
it's hard
psychology is super hard it's way harder
than theoretical physics i can i can
definitely vouch for that the brain is a
complicated thing right
yeah of course and i mean you know
often times as with so many things it's
not so much the individuals doing it so
when we raised this alarm in our 2010
people
lots of psychologists immediately saw
the problem but the institutions are set
up
so that it makes it hard right so if
you're a psychology graduate student
you've got to crank out a few papers
before you graduate and
you're incentivized to find the easiest
most accessible subjects you can find
to run your experiments so things like
learning a language and moving to a
different place or setting up multiple
field sites is just impractical from the
phd perspective
yeah i mean physics has a lot more money
to do these experiments than uh
psychology does i have to say that
also but so the important thing about
this finding is that uh
it's not just well you've studied a
certain population now you have to study
other populations it's
it's that as you already mentioned these
weird
people are not just a point in the
distribution but an extreme point like
we since many of the listeners are going
to be in this in this weird
categorization of
let me let me remember what it is
western educated uh
[Laughter]
supposed to memorize that beforehand but
so since many of us
are that it's interesting to see that we
are the outliers in the distribution
we're not just
specific we are literally different than
most people in a systematic way
yeah yeah and i mean so and lots of
things that psychologists care about so
psychologists for example have been
interested in people's tendency to
conform to their peers
so experiments which are pretty commonly
taught
in introductory classes uh by the
psychologist named solomon ash
show people's willingness to in judging
the lengths of lines go along with their
peers so this pure conformity
and it turns out that uh these weird
people the subjects commonly used by
psychologists
are the least conformist of all the
populations that have been studied
hmm right i mean i think that you have a
whole bunch of
examples of experiments where weird
people are a little bit different than
anyone else and and
some of them kind of make sense to me
that it makes sense to me that there
could be a distribution but others
i was like wow i can't really break out
of my weird box i
really think that the weird people are
just right here so you have this example
of the um
giving money right you know someone has
money and they can give some fraction of
it to someone else who can either accept
it or reject it could you
can you explain that one to us sure so
there's a few different versions of that
but the the most
common one i think that some listeners
might be familiar with
is called the ultimatum game so two
players are allotted a sum of money say
a hundred dollars
and it's the job of the first player
who's called a proposer
to offer a portion of that hundred to
the second player the second player then
has two choices
they can accept the amount of the offer
and then it's
again the game's over it's one shot so
it's not not repeated you don't know the
name of the other person or anything
or they can reject it and if they reject
it both players get zero
and so this was initially done in
industrialized societies
uh in the early 90s and it was found to
be a pretty consistent result
so the modal offers about 50 percent and
mean
offers are about between 40 and 50
percent
and i mean it's interesting you know a
strict utilitarian would say that you
should just accept the offer even if
it's just a penny right
well uh a rational self-interested so
someone who is trying to maximize money
would accept any positive offer any
non-zero offer
because you can think about it from the
point of view of the responder if
they're faced with a choice between say
one dollar
if they accept and zero dollars if they
reject there's no reason to reject so
always accept yeah but so i this is the
example where i can kind of see it both
ways because
clearly if um you know i want some money
so i could accept if they give me a
little bit of money i'll accept it that
makes sense but
also i'm embedded in a culture i'm
better than a society and i imagine that
this kind of transaction might happen
over and over again
i don't want to be you know the mark for
the con game i want to you know stand up
for myself and try to establish some
equilibrium where i get a bunch of money
right and so it turns out that that
varies and in some societies it's really
hard to find someone who will reject
a positive sum of money and you tend to
get low offers now it doesn't go all the
way to zero so
about the lowest mean we found is 25
percent of the total
whereas in other societies you get more
closer to 50 percent
448 might be the mean and most offers
are half
and that's lots of rejections for people
who go below 20 or about 40 or 30
and that's our our weird friends yeah so
pretty common industrialized but
certainly strong and weird populations
and what's interesting is the initial
experiments were done amongst university
students
and they showed the same pattern but
they're actually a little bit weaker it
turns out that
we're still being socialized when we're
20 or 22
and that will continue to get more
willing to reject and
and more you know more concerned about
fairness i guess you could say
i remember uh reading a study i'm not
sure whether it was ever replicated or
not
saying that economists
treat individuals as rationally
self-interested and then when you tested
people and whether they were rationally
self-interested the group that is
most rationally self-interested turned
out to be economics students and
professors like
they're trained into that they're
socialized into it yeah and
that that's that's a finding that has
been replicated
and it's interesting because it turns
out that um
mostly it's by selection into the
discipline
so what they did is they studied
first-year uh freshmen and they can and
seniors in economics and non-economics
and most of the difference say
three-quarters of the difference appears
uh by who becomes an economist
and then you get another one uh over the
four years
but the difference between not
economists and non-economists is
relatively small compared to the
cross-cultural differences that we found
i believe i believe that that makes
sense you did have a sort of throwaway
line in one of your talks that i was
listening to
where you did you or someone did tests
with chimpanzees and they were much
closer to the
ideal economic actor than human beings
were
yeah so after i did the first round of
these experiments in in diverse
societies and we found all this
variation
we started to wonder whether this could
be done with apes and so i worked with a
primatologist named
joan silk and a comparative
experimentalist named danny pavinelli
along with some postdocs uh sarah brazen
and jennifer vonk
and uh so and we studied two different
groups of chimpanzees
uh captive populations and we developed
the simplest game we could think of
which is just to give the chimps two
choices if they pick choice a
they get some food and another chimp
gets some food and if they pick choice b
just they get food and we found that the
chimps were indifferent
uh to which of these they picked so they
so you would you know you would think if
you
even care a tiny bit about others you'd
always pick a
because you get the same amount no
matter what so it's all about whether
the other guy gets anything
and the chimps were indifferent so this
was kind of a selfish response we do
this with young children
and we see concern about others develop
gradually as the kids get older
is this possibly a species-dependent
thing i mean i have a vague recollection
that franz dewall
has experiments with other kinds of
monkeys uh or rather with monkeys
uh where they do seem to be more
empathetic and want to be fair to their
fellow simians yeah so
uh franz has some experiments with
capuchins uh where he actually shows
that when you compare conclusions with
strangers they're
they're just like the chimpanzees but if
you compare them with another member of
their capuchin group
who they know that are familiar with and
they'll go back in the cage after the
experiment
uh then they're they're more generous
yeah that's very interesting yeah this
i told you psychology is much harder
than physics there's always an exception
to every rule
hiring new people is one of the hardest
and most important thing that a small
business can do
with indeed you can hire great people
faster
and you only pay for the results and get
back time on your schedule
indeed.com is the hiring site that helps
find you quality candidates instantly
with indeed
instant match unlike some hiring sites
indeed gives you
full control and payment flexibility
delivering a quality
short list faster and there are no
long-term contracts you can pause your
account at any time
and only pay for what you need indeed
delivers four
times more hires than all other job
sites combined
so if you want your quality short list
fast you need indeed right now our
listeners get a free 75
credit to upgrade your job post at
indeed.com
mindscape this is indeed's best offer
available anywhere
get a free 75 credit at indeed.com
indeed.com mindscape offer valid through
march 31
terms and conditions apply but okay so i
can understand why different cultures
might react differently to that test but
then you have another example where
you're asking about the blame that we
attach to someone for taking someone
else's bag
uh and it depends on whether or not they
did it by accident or intentionally so
why don't you tell us about that one too
sure so we went to 10 different
populations around the world we did it
in los angeles but then we went to
traditional societies
in africa and south america and
ireland southeast asia and we developed
vignettes where
we tried to make it so everybody in each
of these places faced what you might
think of as a theft scenario
we did a few other a harm scenario in a
taboo scenario
but i'll just describe the theft
scenario so people are at a busy market
and someone puts a bag down now
either someone comes up and takes that
bag where we don't set up
it to be an accidental theft and then
another one there a similar bag is
placed next to it
and then the the person mistakenly takes
the wrong bag and so
from the point of view of the the victim
they lose
their bag so they lose their stuff so
the harm to the victim is the same
it's just a question of whether the act
was intentional or could be inferred to
be intentional
or whether it was clearly accidental
right and we found that the folks in los
angeles
and also we did some work in the in
rural ukraine where at the extreme end
of the distribution
uh so most concerned about intention in
terms of whether the person should be
punished
meaning that the person who took the bag
and what not uh and
and then it went all the way down to
folks in fiji who didn't
didn't make use of intentions at all so
they weren't concerned about people's
mental states they
they judged the thief equally harshly in
both conditions
and that's what i really do have trouble
uh wrapping my brain around and this is
it's a great example of how things that
we think of as
purely rational are in fact extremely
culturally conditioned right i mean
to me it just seems obvious that intent
should matter like would you when you
want to blame
someone their their intent for doing the
thing that they're you're blaming them
for
is clearly relevant but there's a whole
nother way of thinking that discounts
that
yeah so uh some societies are are have
strict what they call strict liability
so that's kind of the legal term
which would mean that if you kill
someone it doesn't matter
whether you did it by accident you say
your arrow uh ricochet off a deer and
hit pit a person
or whether you actually shot them
because there's a loss of life
a loss of a person and so the penalty to
you is the same
and you see this in a lot of
anthropological work on traditional law
so in societies that have blood revenge
if members of one clan
kill another clan then if the proper
blood money isn't paid doesn't matter
whether it's on purpose or by accident
uh you can murder someone
in the clan that from which the murderer
comes and there's no sense in which it
has to be the person who did the
murdering
because the other members of the clan
are interchangeable so you could just as
easily kill their brother
even though he wasn't involved right
yeah so he's completely innocent
so this is something you see throughout
the anthropological record in lots of
societies
and is this somehow i don't want to you
know push the data beyond what they're
able to tell us but
is this somehow indicating some
sense in which different cultures
approach the theory of minds of others
in some way you know the the fact we we
conceptualize other people
as making choices and that's the locus
of good or badness those choices those
individuals are making
yeah so i think that that's pretty
important um it's hard to get it just
from this data but if you look at other
we've done some theory of mind studies
and other studies looking at people's
mental states there's a line of
kind of historical literature on this
and in the
western kind of european tradition
there's an increasing emphasis on
thinking about what's inside people as
animating their characteristics it could
be their dispositions yeah
it could be honest it could be their
mental states and this is how we this is
our sort of gut reaction to explain
behavior
it's something about that person what he
believes what kind of person he is his
personality
something like that whereas in lots of
other places there's much more emphasis
on the kind of
social world as marionette you know as
as the holding the strings to the
marionette
so uh the social ties so who who are his
alliances you know
where his allegiances this kind of what
are social relationships and that can be
used to explain people's behavior
and of course we can do that in both
systems and you know that kind of
explanation can make intuitive sense
to weird people like me uh but it's not
our first inclination when we go to
explain something
and when we're looking to make our way
through the world well and this is one
of the
i guess we should get a little bit more
systematically into what it means to be
weird
in in your sense one of their aspects is
this
analytic thinking versus holistic
thinking i guess is the
is the dichotomy here and you know to me
again it's because i am embedded in this
and i'm admitting it
you know analytic thinking that's a good
thing it's just sort of thinking
carefully about things but
is it a matter of like what you look at
first do you look at the parts first
and then put them together if you're an
analytic thinker versus looking at the
whole and then maybe subdividing if
you're more holistic thinker
yeah it's kind of it and it also affects
it
it's very deep in the sense that if it
affects even the things you pay
attention to
so if our decisions and our kind of data
taking process as you know
uh intelligence is moving through the
world is affected by what we attend to
then this analytic thinking is important
because
analytic thinkers tend to focus on the
focal object
and holistic thinkers tend to look and
they remember more of what's in the
background
and when you do eye tracking you find
that some populations will just attend
more and then remember more things in
the background
whereas the more analytic thinkers are
focusing on the foreground and looking
at the kind of
main object or whatever the individual
is other data suggests that you know
the immediate reaction of an analytic
thinker is to figure out what the parts
are
so if you're a physicist you might you
know break things down into particles
and give them properties
and then the system is explained by the
particular properties of the particles
that you assign it to
whereas if you're more of an analytic
thinker you think about the
relationships you mean hold on
you said you said if you're more of an
analytic thinker you meant more of a
holistic thinker
oh sorry yeah more of a holistic thinker
you're thinking about the relationships
between the particles
so for example like i like to think
about explaining
human behavior this way uh an analytic
thinker thinks like an economist right
they assign
preferences and beliefs and then they
explain people's behavior based on
preferences and beliefs properties of
individuals
whereas a holistic thinker looks at the
relationships so if someone's behaving
uh as a thief or something like that
then the holistic thinker is going to be
like
well he probably doesn't like that
person or maybe that person took someone
something from him or
you know they would use the context or
relationships to explain it rather than
saying you know that person is dishonest
and assigning them a disposition
right and so it seems like analytic maps
on to sort of a reductionist view of the
world
is that a fair thing is yeah yeah and in
the book i mean then i move into kind of
some speculative thinking towards the
end of the book but i think you can see
this
in in science in the emergence of
science because one of the first moves
of scientists of course is to
try to break things down into their
little bits and then then figure out how
they fit back together once you got the
bits
so maybe i should uh let you put into
words
you know that what exactly what are the
first things we should think of when you
say
the weird psychology i mean this
analytic thinking is part of it
clearly individualism is a huge part of
it but you know what
what are the three words we should
remain remember ten years from now for
listening to this podcast about what
weirdness really entails
well yeah i think your first point is
always the one i open with which is
thinking about the individuals and
focusing on their attributes and
aspirations
instead of thinking about people's uh
relationships
so this is associated kind of
psychologically with things like
overconfidence
and a tendency to self-enhance rather
than being kind of a humble
uh to kind of put forth your your your
best what you think are your best
attributes
another one is the one we've been
talking about which is analytic thinking
so approaching things looking for
categories and assigning properties as
opposed to
looking at background relationships and
context
another one is is concern with
impartial principles over uh the kind of
in-group loyalty and social
relationships that govern so much social
structure
so those are three big ones i wonder
have you studied uh
sort of consequentialist versus
deontological versions of morality
right i mean you know deontological
being like here are the rules we should
obey
them consequentialist being like let's
go and do whatever it takes to get the
best outcome it sounds like
weird people would be more
consequentialist and in other cultures
traditional cultures might be more
deontological
yeah um i i think that that that broadly
holds true
um the only thing that's tricky is in a
lot of
the experiments that uh are used to do
that
the individuals it's kind of a weird
experiment in the sense that the
like you use these trolley problems uh
and the individuals are often
none of the relationship information is
specified right so i think you could
really pick up the differences if you
started talking about
the relationships you know who they were
or what their ethnic linguistic group
was
what their relationships are do they
know anybody you know things like that
and that's kind of like the uh non-weird
people are much more interested like
that's the information they want to know
because that feeds into their decision
making
whereas it's much easier to even
entertain the
abstract question uh if you're weird
because
you're like what are the key principles
here you know let me do the counting if
you're utilitarian
yeah okay that makes sense so the the
utility because the people who invented
the trolley problem are weird exactly
they don't they don't care what your
relationship is with the people on the
on the tracks they just care how many of
them there are
they're trying to illustrate a principle
or multiple principles here i see okay
so
so we weird folks are are more
individualistic
um one of the phrases that i got uh out
of your writing was
um uh favoring impersonal pro-sociality
over interpersonal
relationships so in some sense we're
individualistic we think about ourselves
um but that makes us more uh
i don't want to say fair but at least
more uniform in our dealing with others
rather than favoring our kin group
or something like that yeah yeah so
and there's often this kind of tension
in how people think about this because
i mean this i think too is a weird trait
people think either you're cooperative
or not cooperative
and actually what the world looks like i
think is that it's about who you're
cooperative with right
and so you can think of kind of social
distance from yourself or from your
group and
you know how what's the kind of uh
slope of the line that moves away from
you is it is it you know really steep
such that people who are far away from
you are essentially strangers and you're
treating them
with self-interest you know you're
behaving self-interestedly toward them
or is it much more shallow so that you
know your second cousin
is not very different from a stranger
when you're if you're trying to make a a
choice between
how some policy is going to affect them
or who you're going to hire or something
like that
yeah and one of the ways this shows up
is in the difference between
guilt versus shame uh both of which
sound
sound bad but uh the weird cultures are
much more interested in guilt roughly
speaking
right right and so the key to
understanding this is that i think the
key
is that um when you're trying to
navigate your way through a weird
individualistic world you've gotta
you're looking for relationships so you
might be looking for business
relationships or co-authors if you're an
academic
um you're looking for mates spouses
friends and in each case they're you
know you're cultivating an individual
uniqueness so what do i bring to this
what's what's interesting about me that
people might want to hang out with me or
marry me or or write a paper with me
and uh in in the more relational world
what you bring is a set of relationships
and you're bored into these
relationships and you're looking
you're trusting people who are who
you're connected to through sets of
relationships
so uh if in this world we are
cultivating this unique individual self
guilt plays a big role because you've
set some personal standards for yourself
so i'm going to go to the gym and i'm
going to read interesting books
and so you're kind of you know you feel
guilty if you don't do those things even
though those aren't social norms in your
society and people aren't going to look
badly on you if they find out
you skipped the gym and took a nap or
something like that uh
so and but in a shame society it's a lot
about complying with the social norms
and not
being the tall poppy that stands out so
so there you're much more concerned with
shane how you look in the eyes of others
and this gives this contrast which is a
very old idea in anthropology that there
are shame societies and guilt societies
but we you know psychology and other and
actually the web has provided ways to
to measure the difference between
populations and how much they're worried
about these
you know peter singer has this thought
experiment where you know someone is
drowning and you walk by
uh and you could save them would you do
it
uh and most people would you know try to
do it and then he's like well but
there's thousands of people you could
save
in africa who you don't know uh with
that much effort or even much less why
don't you do that and
i guess the implicit thing going on
there is that every life
is equally worthy and i know that i know
that
i think that you're about the sort of
descriptive side of things not the
normative side of things but
it almost our weirdness almost sneaks in
as an
unspoken assumption to how we should
think about
right and wrong right like it's it we
take it for granted that we should
think about all lives equally even if we
don't always act that way but there's a
whole other way of thinking
that would say well of course it matters
a lot more to me if
my cousin is drowning than if someone i
don't know
right and so i i make the case that it's
this psychological transformation
that focus on individualism and
impartial principles
that kind of open the door for things
like universal human rights
where we're you know we're making this
species level generation we still keep
the non-humans out of it but we say that
all humans should
have certain rights privileges things
like that and that's a very weird way of
thinking
peter singer does not keep the uh other
species out of it by the way
he wants to get rid of that of course
yeah but that's that's interesting that
the circle continues to expand even
beyond right beyond homo sapiens very
right
uh and so good and so we're more
individualistic
more analytic um there's another aspect
which
it's because i care about time and the
universe a lot i have to emphasize which
is
the idea i think that weird people are
more future oriented or maybe even if i
can be bolder
more willing to extend their selfhood to
other places and times and
uh take actions uh accordingly to try to
you know do things now that will benefit
my future self
right right so there are these
experiments uh one is the famous
marshmallow test where you give
children a choice between one
marshmallow now or two if they wait
and they actually end up in the
experiment there's a little bit of
deception the children are just
you're waiting to see if he caves in and
eats the marshmallow
uh and there's some limited time like 15
or 20 minutes
and and then another one is where you
give people choices between you know 100
now or 130 in a year yeah and have
people make a series of binary choices
and that seems to vary a lot around the
world and i
i suggest and they're various amounts of
evidence to support this
that it's just you know that the ability
to cultivate that deferring of
gratification was fostered by these
institutions that were developing in
europe
in 1500 1600 in which you could save
money you could individually own
things and so there were real incentives
for cultivating this kind of
long-term savings and this particular
way of thinking about money
uh and then the protestant things like
protestant thinking and whatnot even
encourage that more
so there's a relationship between
protestantism and this deferring
gratification
kind of this is a they vary an idea and
uh yeah so i think that and so there's
probably a bunch of these little
ratchets that help push up
push up our patients that are built into
our institutions yeah i mean the
the origin of it i want to definitely
get to that i'm sort of biting my tongue
about why we became weird because it's
so interesting and i want to
get all the weirdness on the table first
before we ask where it came from
um but because there's so many different
aspects and i i wonder if there is a
grand unified theory of it all
i mean another aspect is this idea of
authenticity
and presenting different selves or faces
to the world
like we we weird people think that there
is a
virtue in being the same when we talk to
different sets of people
whereas non-weird societies apparently
from what i read in your book uh
just take for granted we would act
differently in different circumstances
yeah and the key to i think
understanding that is there's lots of
relationships that are
prescribed to be certain ways so how you
treat elders or how you treat parents
and
a lot of times you'll call multiple
people father or mother
um and there might even be people who
you'll have a classicaltory relationship
so you'll
you'll call them uncle even though
they're not really your uncle and part
of what that's telling you is how you're
supposed to treat him like you would
treat an uncle
and you have a whole series of rules and
uh prescriptions about how you treat
different kinds of relatives
so for example uh famously in lots of
societies there are these cross-cousin
relationships
so um this for example would be your
your
mother's mother's brother's son would
would be your crosscut would be wanting
one of your cross cousins
and you have a joking relationship with
them so constant practical jokes making
fun of each other
is just a normal way to behave but you
never behave that way to your
grandfather
and so so these these very different
ways of behaving
and you know of course that that we can
understand that
we're weird psychology can understand
that but there is a much
bigger premium on being consistent
across
so if you have certain attitudes you're
supposed to have those attitudes
as you meet different people and appear
in different situations
and if you don't you know people can
think of you as two-faced or
hypocritical
uh so we have these very critical terms
whereas in other in other traditions
it can be thought to be wise and
sensible yeah uh to
to not always present the same face in a
different situation
2020 was full of unique challenges that
made us change our whole way of life but
with each challenge
we learned learn to survive to thrive
and strive to be better
we don't know what 2021 will bring but
with the great courses plus
you can make this your year by
continuing to learn with purpose
with the great courses plus the
opportunities to learn are endless you
get unlimited access
to stream thousands of video and audio
courses from top
experts in their fields from how to
build a better business plan to play
guitar like a pro
one course i can recommend is nuclear
physics explained by professor lawrence
weinstein
it offers compelling and expert insights
analyzing the science from every angle
you'll get everything you want to know
about how quarks form together with
gluons to make protons and neutrons
how to fuse those together to make
bigger items or fission them apart
to make littler ones so sign up for the
great courses plus by visiting this
special url
thegreatcoursesplus.com mindscape
and you'll get 14 days of unlimited
access for free
you don't want to pass this up so go now
to th e
great courses plus dot com slash
mindscape
yeah unlike the uh you know
intentionality and blame
business here i can very much sympathize
with the non-weird uh
situation uh attitude towards these
things you know i do
question whether or not this
valorization of hemp is having a single
unified self that behaves the same way
to
uh all different people in all different
circumstances uh
is something that we should hold up as a
good thing you know i i guess
that's a little bit of sympathetic
towards the non-weird side for me
and and you know but nonetheless there
is a kind of popular discourse about you
know finding your true self
oh yeah right people are always trying
to kind of look for that thing down
there somewhere in there if i can just
find it i'll be happy
and it it uh just to just sort of finish
these you know ticking off some of the
weird boxes um there's the idea that
maybe stems from our individuality
of that we have free will right that we
can make
choices that are rooted in our personal
volition that then affect the rest of
the world and i was surprised to hear
that this is a weird trait as well
well yeah so i think it begins uh you
can see it with these moralizing
religions so it's
more than just weird but it just gets
accentuated
in the western tradition where a great
deal of emphasis is placed on these
making of these individual choices
uh but yeah it probably it has seeds
that go back into the moralizing
religions which have spread to lots of
places
because you have to make choices that
will affect whether you get into heaven
and things like that and other
traditions
i see okay that's i mean so how do we
how do we
experimentally test when free will
came on the scene i mean how do we is
that this is a job for
cultural anthropology i guess uh well so
i mean there's
i mean it's no there's a lot of research
to be done on this but there is a
historical literature where they try to
look
you know at different religious texts
and back into time to try to find
discussions of free will
so saint augustine in the western
tradition you know spends a lot of time
on this
anthropologists of course have provided
lots of data from diverse societies and
and some of this provides insights into
whether there's free will
and then you can run experiments and the
way they do psychologists have done
experiments on this
is actually with a technique called
priming so they have subjects
read our philosophical arguments that
either argue
for the existence of free will or argue
against it
and then they have to make decisions or
do some psychological tasks
after they've been been primed in favor
of pre-will or
suggested that free will doesn't work
like you know do you want to have
cookies after it how many cookies are
you going to take or
you have to make a decision about
allocating money to charity or to
yourself
and how does believing relatively more
or free will or less
affect those decisions and sorry so what
is what is the
answer well at least when you do it with
western subjects when you prime them
with free will
they give more to charity so they're
more generous so it's
yeah because they're giving themselves
credit right i mean it sort of fits in
with
yeah and they they i think they eat less
cookies too
[Laughter]
yeah i don't know uh my my dietary
habits have become worse
in the pandemic so i blame the world not
my individual choices whatsoever
of course um but in another another
crucial aspect of this
um i mean maybe i should you know pause
here to ask
uh how well have we done in sketching
out the
the attributes that we that we associate
with weirdness is there anyone that
we're missing or have we given the
people uh
the basic picture i think we've we've
given a good overview one thing that i
i think is interesting you submit you
mentioned you're interested in time
so how we think about time i think was
shaped over this
cultural evolutionary period and
so we tend to think about time in
absolute sense and many of us were
trained in a world where we we watched a
clock right so i'm getting a clock with
numbers where that where the hand moves
around the clock
and that's actually a number line a
linear number line that's been wrapped
around in a circle
and it kind of teaches us that time is
linear uh but when you look at past
practices it's not clear that people saw
time as linear
the way we do because the seat you know
the day would
would change the length of the day would
change assuming you know depending on
what latitude you're at
and that the day would flex so like the
length of hours actually varied in
lots of societies where at some point in
europe they developed a constant hour
right it's always 60 minutes
and they began even before the the
mechanical clock kind of spread rapidly
throughout europe
people were using candlesticks and
hourglasses and things like that to
measure time and there seemed to be
almost an
obsession with measuring time and a real
concern with it so wait so wage labor
became hourly right so
suddenly you're measuring money and time
can be put together
and of course ben franklin coins the
meta or the you know time is money
um and then we talk about time like it's
money like we're always trying to buy
time
save time running out of time those
kinds of things
well actually it only now occurs to me
that you say that um when i had a
conversation a few months ago with lara
borditzki who uh
studies language and and metaphors for
time usually spatial metaphors right
like time is
going up or down or forward or backward
like every i think i don't think we
talked about time is money as a metaphor
but yes of course
uh it's valuable you know we spend it
and and and so forth yeah that makes
perfect sense so you're saying that
we can sort of look to pinpoint when
that became a cultural metaphor
yeah well so we know that ben made it up
right but then is course
you know in a much longer cultural
tradition where it looks like people
became increasingly concerned with time
and one simple marker of this is just
the diffusion of the mechanical clock
yeah so kind of 13th 14th century
mechanical clocks start diffusing
and they start in italy but they rapidly
go from city to pity
and over trying to one-up other towns
and they would ring bells and then fled
to the city kind of
literally running like clockwork like
they ring the bell and everybody you
know
wakes up and then has breakfast and then
you know there's the lunch bell
and so you the city begins to run like
clockwork but the clock doesn't diffuse
into the middle east
and other cultures didn't seem to have
the the immense interest in getting a
hawk the way the europeans do
huh that is very interesting have you
ever read um einstein's clock's ponca
raised maps by your harvard colleague
peter gallison
oh it's on my list i haven't read it
very worth reading yeah and one of the
points he makes a little bit
past the eras you're talking about but
he makes the point that einstein never
would have invented relativity if he
hadn't been
a patent clerk who it was a clerk at a
time when clocks were a big deal and he
was thinking about you know
synchronizing time over different cities
and that helped him to think about what
it meant to synchronize time
yeah that's a great that's a great
example so uh
this yeah this is this business about
time is very very good and
important because it it is hard to break
out of how we think about
the world and to realize that you know
there are other ways of thinking about
it not only in cultures
uh in different parts of the world but
even in our ancestral
cultures the idea that we de-emphasize
being individuals having free will
keeping track of time is just a hard one
for us to do one of the things you
emphasize is the co-evolution
of genes and culture right the fact that
these uh shifts and ways of thinking
play back and forth with the
with shifts in our actual genomes
yeah so in my my previous book the
secret of our success i
argue that lots of the uh features of
our of
of humans has been shaped by culture so
things like the way tools and fire have
shaped our hands and our
our intestines and our digestive systems
and then i think a lot of our
big brains expanded as a response of
having to learn lots of cultural
information about how to make tools and
uh shelters and uh put you know arrow
poisons and things like that
so this complex body of knowledge that
transmits non-genetically
in many ways i think our brains have
evolved to be to be good at acquiring
all that information
and one of the um one of the interesting
differences between weird and non-weird
cultures
is shows up in the hemispheres of our
brains i mean maybe this is not a
physiological difference but
uh the idea that we're not as good at
looking at recognizing faces for example
so uh yeah crucial distinction so um it
is a physiological difference it's just
not a genetic difference
right so there's a lot a lot more to
biology than just genetics and so
as a consequence of learning to read as
we grow up
there's a bunch of changes that we can
see in people's brains and so
neuroscientists and cognitive scientists
have done a lot of work on this
and you can study illiterate populations
and they seem to see faces for example
uh equally the show if you look at the
brain activation you get equally in the
left and right hemispheres
it's only when you learn to read that
the facial recognition is driven
somewhat
out of the left hemisphere so that we so
that people
neuroscientists thought that humans you
know humans the species
were right hemisphere bias for facial
recognition but it seems like that's all
or mostly a product of the fact that
they studied mostly uh literate
populations
and of course throughout most of human
history people have been illiterate
so it's only recently that we became
right hemisphere biased and facial
recognition
and that's because there's a lot of
neurogeography used for recognizing
words
and processing words quickly and of
course so and we also have things like a
thicker corpus callosa
so the information a highway that
connects the left and right hemispheres
we have other psychological patterns for
literate populations where
when we hear speech we get more whole
brain activation
maybe because parts of our brain are
kind of turning it into letters
and that's another way to store it and
represent it and interact with it
i have to ask is there some knowledge
about what breaks the
symmetry between the right and left side
of the brains i mean
you know i would have expected that half
of the children who become literate
uh have that those parts of their brains
that do that
on the right half and half have it on
the left half but there's something
systematic
well yeah that's so it's building on a i
mean i'm not a neuroscientist but my
reading of this
work is that there's already an
asymmetry in humans brains that we have
language centers on the left okay so
noro geographically you've got to see
the reading near the language because
obviously they're connected uh and then
there's also object recognition
and that's where you start impinging on
the the neurogeography usually used for
faces
but yeah it's the left bias because
that's where languages i see so the
difference between left and right brains
is there
even in pre-literate societies but
basically literate societies
have this whole extra thing that they
need to associate with language namely
reading
and that sort of grows in the brain and
pushes facial recognition to the other
side
yeah yeah and one of the fascinating
parts of it is of course
uh scripts that we use for reading you
know you can think of chinese characters
or kanji characters or
uh arabic script or all or hebrew
they're all very
they're different i mean they're the
same in many ways but they're different
in certain key and interesting ways
uh but yet the area of the brain that
gets transformed for reading is
more or less in the same place it's not
exactly in the same place but
amazingly it doesn't pop up anywhere it
pops up within this certain certain area
in the brain and of course it's
it can't be uh genetic right like
we haven't been reading that long to
evolve a new part of our brain
yeah and so this is one of the points
that i try to get across in my last book
in this book
is we have to get beyond this kind of
dualistic way of thinking
where there's genetic things that we
think of as biological
and then there's cultural learned things
which seem to be almost you know
ethereal
uh when we learn culture that wires
things into our brains and you know
whether we're learning a language or
we're learning to juggle
uh if we're learning the complexity of
streets in london we know that this
alters for example our hippocampus
and so you get physical changes in the
substructure which means that
cultural evolution is a kind of
biological evolution it's just not a
kind of genetic evolution
right so to be clear on what that means
it's it's something that can affect our
um ability to reproduce and pass things
down to further generations but it's
just not encoded in our dna
exactly and it's actually transmitted so
something like the protestantism or
values in education
teaching kids to read is something
that's passed from one generation to the
next
and that that then affects how people
behave in the world they learn to read
and that then
alters their noro circuitry in their
left hemisphere right
and okay so good so speaking of
protestants uh that's good
this is uh probably the time we should
talk about where all this came from i
mean you you've convinced me
i think it's a pretty easy target for
the the claim that
uh weird populations are different and
the specific ways in which they're
different make perfect sense to me um
it seems to be much harder claim to make
to really understand
where that came from but you're boldly
doing it as a
as a good scholar is supposed to do so
uh should we start even
you know very early in societies with
how society's scale up
um you know back in the early days of
the switch from
hunter-gathering to agriculture
yeah so you know i'm here i'm mostly
drawing on
uh work in anthropology and archaeology
i mean jared diamond summarizes some of
this stuff in his book gun sherms and
steel
but the central idea is that with the
beginnings of agriculture you could have
food production so you could have larger
populations
and as populations scale up they've got
to control land and territory in order
to do agriculture so you need to get
groups to cooperate on larger scales
and one of the perhaps the main way that
societies do this when they first begin
to scale up
is they switch from what's called
extensive kinship so you're building
social relationships the way a hunter a
mobile hunter-gatherer band would where
you have
uh you're building social links that go
far away
so that you have this broad network of
people you can depend on depending on
whether there's shocks or
other kinds of things you can move
around the landscape to different
friends and
different places uh just to a really
intense group that can defend some
territory so a clan
where everybody's related they all see
themselves as owners of the land
and they're all going to fight fiercely
to control this territory
and so that's kind of how we start
getting larger groups we get
clans and that we can get groups of
clans there's things called age sets
with which create bonds between clans
there's another social structure called
segmentary lineage
which is another way that plants can get
together to control territory
and the scaling up process and so i make
the case that this
created a certain kind of social network
uh based on kin ties
cousin marriage structures like the klan
where we see ourselves as related to
an ancestor in the past um there's
inheritance rules that help bind us
together residence rules about where
people
live after they get married that sets
who you're going to grow up with and who
you perform these links with
so all this affects our social structure
and that then affects our psychology and
in some of the ways we talked about
giving this more holistic thinking
concern about
clan loyalty or social relationships
um or conformity things like that right
so just to be clear this this sort of
development of
clan structure or in kinship relations
that's not the weirdness that's the
thing that the weirdness will eventually
sort of react against so
early humans around the world uh develop
this sort of
clan kinship structure
exactly so this is this is occurring as
societies scale up
and there's a lot of scaling up that's
being driven by the emergence of food
production so
animal domestication and you know
agriculture especially things like rice
based agriculture wheat-based
agriculture
are particularly strong in this kind of
scaling up process so there's lots of
ecological factors that we think are
relevant to this
but then you get to the earliest states
and what they seem to be is you know
group stratify so you get one set of kin
relations that are the elites
and then lower strata which could all go
all the way down to slaves
and aside from the slaves everybody is
linked together through these kin ties
so kin ties take care of when you're
injured they
determine who you're going to marry or
at least have a big influence on it
um and they take you know take care of
take care of you when
you're old so they're you know you're
really woven into a tight social fabric
there
but states begin to have these
bureaucracies so they could be military
bureaucracies or judicial
bureaucracies they're often religious
elements to all this that
allow these larger groups of the first
states merge
and the case that i make in the book is
this creates a kind of path dependence
because
so much of these early states were
dependent on these tight kin bonds
that it was there was no pathway
essentially from an evolutionary
perspective
to the kinds of societies to modern
societies today
which are based on these small families
where the economic and political
institutions
aren't interwoven with these big kinship
bonds and what not in
you know those are those kind of got to
be kept suppressed
uh and so then the question is how did
you ever get to the point where you
could
build this other you could go down this
other trajectory i mean
is this something we can compare in any
useful way
to primates to gorillas and monkeys and
and so forth uh are they
are they weirder than most human beings
um well i guess they're uh they're
weirder i mean
uh the the thing about other non-human
primates
is that they don't have uh culture so
they're not gonna have social norms and
institutions
i mean you know you could say that
gorillas have a kind of despotism
because they have these silver-backed
males who control this harem of females
uh so i mean there are some parallels
like that
but what i think is interesting is that
you know
in mobile hunter-gatherer societies
they're sort of weirder in the sense
that
they don't have these clans or other
kind of tight bonds okay so when
psychologists have done experiments like
simple perception experiments uh a
famous one is
measures field independence they're they
look more like weird people so they're
field independent
just like weird people and it's really
the agriculturalists who are field
dependent
and this has to do with your ability to
see things independently moving in space
aside from the background
so it has that kind of analytic versus
holistic feel to it
right i wonder this is probably too far
to go but um
i do wonder if this is has theological
implications for the difference between
you know judeo-christian ways of
thinking about humanity versus
buddhist or confusion or taoist ways of
thinking about
who we are and how we fit into the
universe
yeah and i certainly i mean it turns out
that in the modern world 90 percent of
christians are cultural descendants of
this
of this western european tradition so
this wasn't true when things started so
the
the branch of christianity that
eventually evolved into the roman
catholic church
was you know just one branch among many
there were syrian christians and
armenian christians and
uh ethiopian christians chaldean
christians
but the this there was such an explosion
of this one particular branch rooted in
the catholic church that it
that that dominates much of what we
think of as christian thought today
right and you in particular this is sort
of the major
point i guess at least that people seize
on uh you want to put your finger on the
very specific idea that the church tells
you not to marry your cousin
as a real turning point in in the makeup
psychologically of uh weird people
versus the non-weird
well i want to i'd want to expand a
little bit beyond that because i
i think that the key element is the way
that the
brand of christianity that eventually
becomes roman catholicism
they did a whole bunch of things to the
family so they uh
banned cousin marriage they altered the
inheritance system
uh this in ways that would have ended
clans
uh they ended polygeny um they had
they preferred neo-local residents they
tried to end arranged marriages
and all of these things kind of point in
the direction of creating monogamous
nuclear families
so you know i was making this case
earlier about how
there's this path dependence problem so
yeah the early states are all interwoven
with these dense kinship networks that
grew up during the
agricultural period when we were
completely dependent on agriculture and
had to control territory
so how do you get around that well the
church is is what
you know allowed this other path to to
spring up because it
it broke all that stuff down into
monogamous nuclear families even
even less intensive kinship than we see
amongst hunter gatherers
and then the question is well how do we
how do we create a world where
we can only have monogamous nuclear
families because they're taboos and
marrying our cousins and we can't have
unilineal defense systems
uh and you get these new institutions
these voluntary institutions and
these representative governments that
pop up in the high middle ages
one of the things about the modern world
is that life is becoming less
predictable
we don't live in the same house
generations at a time anymore
our jobs might change from when we're 20
and 30 to when we're 40 and 50.
costs are rising the cost of living
student debt buying a house and so forth
for all of these reasons it makes sense
why people get life insurance
especially term coverage which is
surprisingly affordable
why not pay a bit each month to protect
the ones you love
if you're asking yourself this question
consider choosing
ladder ladder makes it impressively fast
and easy to get covered you just need a
few minutes
and a phone or a laptop to apply
ladder's smart algorithms work in real
time so you'll find out instantly if
you're approved
there are no hidden fees you can cancel
at any time and since life insurance
costs more as you age
now is the time to cross it off your
list so check out ladder today to see if
you're instantly approved
go to ladderlife.com mindscape
that's l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
mindscape so the idea is that uh
if you can't marry or you know if yeah
if
if if the family unit is a monogamous
relationship
uh hopefully uh one where people are
uh have marital fidelity uh
then there's just less room for
constructing a large group of people who
are all
kin in some sense uh right you're not
you're not marrying within the same
remarrying within the same group over
and over again
but you still need social relations and
therefore you're you're sort of nudged
towards making social relations with
people who you're not kin with is that
an oversimplification but okay
uh yeah i know i mean that that gets him
to gets at the major thrust
uh and the key to remember is the degree
to which as an individual
in these worlds of intensive kinship
you're dependent on this
kin network for your you know it's the
people who you cooperate with
economically
uh it's you know your political power in
rome of course there is a patriarchal
society so only the head of the family
had any legal rights
so you would you know even if you're an
adult you could be a 40 year old man if
your father's alive
you're under his you know you're under
his legal umbrella
in some sense and uh
so there's no individual rights or
anything like that in in this other
world
but then because everything gets broken
down into monogamous nuclear families
people need to figure out ways to create
mutual insurance and to
you know have some security when they're
old and when they get injured
and then you know who are my allies like
who am i i don't have this network of
kin i can tap if i need
to defend my honor or you know being
harassed by someone
and so and so they built these voluntary
associations so
guilds begin as a kind of mutual
insurance network
and you get universities and monasteries
you know and a whole variety of
different
institutions that are all doing the same
thing they're creating they're doing the
social functions that kinship groups
used to do
yeah and this whole idea of sort of
cosmopolitanism and
and the idea that you could like move to
other places and
and start a life and and associate with
people who are not in your family
you're saying that all sort of comes
from this idea uh
that the church wants the family unit to
be relatively tiny
yeah and you know it's it's not the key
here is that the as best i can tell
there's no intention right in the church
they're just kind of following what they
think god wants and it has this
unexpected byproduct effect uh and
a key one is the one you mentioned there
which is this residential mobility
so you find in lots of places people are
still tied back to the to the rural
farms and stuff so i see this in fiji
i've seen it described in china
uh in africa so they still have
responsibilities
and obligations back home but they go to
the city maybe to make money or you know
for some short period
when they're there they're probably
living with relatives or at least people
from the region where they come from
and they're just spending some time
there whereas when you break everyone
down to nuclear families there's nothing
to go back home to
like there's not some big network of kin
you're not tied to ancestors who are
buried in your land so you have
ritual responsibilities you can just
move to the town and become a citizen of
the town
so what you get are new towns sprouting
up all over europe
where people would join and they'd be
members and this is you know this is
where the idea of citizenship comes from
citizen of a town and by joining i
signed a contract i swear an oath to god
that i'll fulfill my responsibilities
and obligations to this to this town to
this group of strangers that i'm joined
and since many of our listeners are
probably in this weird group um
does that do you mean to imply by this
that in non-weird societies
that wouldn't happen this idea of like
going to a town and becoming a citizen
of it is just much less common
uh well so today things have changed of
course because a lot of these
institutions have been exported around
the world
but in you know in former times and kind
of you know think about the medieval
period yeah uh
it certainly wouldn't have worked where
you'd kind of where you're joining like
a voluntary association
right so for example i looked at the
spread of representative governments and
one of the chapters in my book shows how
that the more years a region of europe
had under the church
the more likely you're a talent you're
you're likely to see representative
governments pop up in a town
um during that exact same period the
frequency of representative governments
popping up in the islamic world is zero
like there's not a single case of
representative government popping up so
it's just a different way of thinking
about the world i want to actually give
you a chance to expand on
these data because they really are
wonderful you have all these plots about
how long a certain culture has been
exposed to the ideas of the western
church
versus various measures of individuality
and cosmopolitanism
et cetera it's actually quite nice to
see that kind of quantitative evidence
yeah so what we did and this is working
with three economics colleagues is we
put together
all the data we could find uh that
measured psychology
and then we put together data from
anthropological databases on kinship
structure
so we're able to show the places that
have more of this intensive kinship as
i've described it
has a bunch of the psychological
patterns that we've been talking about
and often they're pretty strong
correlations
and then we try to figure well how can
we measure church exposure
so we built a database of the diffusion
of the catholic church across
europe so for each each bishopric so
that's kind of
an administrative hub within catholicism
we know it's gps coordinates and it's
data founding
and so then we can take a person who's
in a survey and tag him in space and
tag him in space and then say how long
that region has been
under the catholic church and then we
can use that to predict these features
of psychology
that we can get from survey measures or
when we go globally we can get from
other kinds of measures
i know that you already sort of demured
the question
of why the church took this policy you
said that's what they think god did we
do we know anything more about
specifically
why this was a choice that was made
particularly in the western
church and not you know in the islamic
world or china or india or any place
like that
yeah so uh there's a couple different
ways of looking at that so first
uh you know it's a bit of a complex
picture so there's certainly
some early church fathers who seem to
recognize what they would have what you
could describe as the social benefits or
the
the the way of expanding the circle of
society by
preventing cousin marriage so saint
augustine writes about this a bit
but then when you read you try to read
up on what the actual
uh what's happening at these councils
and the debates
it doesn't seem to have come up very
much that social benefits
people are more concerned about well
there's a plague hitting and god's angry
with us
for for not adhering you know there's
too much incest by which they mean too
much cousin marriage
and we've got to really crack down on
this cousin marriage so they would
increase the penalties and expand the
circle
uh and do things like that and so so
there's that feature the other thing
that the
uh jack goody has argued is that this
benefited the church financially
so the church gets a lot of revenue
flows from simple things like selling
the
chance to marry your cousin but also
from
uh bequests so christians elite
christians became convinced that
if they wanted to get into heaven and
they were rich they had to give to the
poor
and of course if you give to the poor
while you're living that can be
inconvenient
but if you give on your deathbed then
then that's a lot more convenient
so a lot of people were making massive
deathbed bequests of land to the church
and the church became the largest
landowner in europe
uh so you know this was at least a
profitable thing to do now whether
you know it's a debate among historians
and there's a lot of critics of of goody
because there's no smoking gun evidence
where the church is like yeah yeah we're
going to get a big wealth flow if we
if we just implement this so you know
it's easy to believe that
various bishops may have noticed that
this is this is you know fills their
coffers
so maybe that you know they're more
likely to go along with the policy
they're more likely to implement it
um but i think that really the deeper
and more important point which is often
missed in how we think about things
we tend to want to look for the kind of
rationalization or justification when we
see some
someone do something that ends up being
successful and so certainly the catholic
church is successful whatever else you
think about it
but uh yeah it's important to realize
that other groups were trying other
kinds of experiments so over in persia
zoroastrians were encouraging cousin
marriage and even encouraging brother
sister marriage and incest
at the elite levels and islam was trying
to constrain polygamy but just to four
wives
but they had an inheritance custom that
said that daughters had to have
inherit half of what sons inherit which
led to a very unusual practice of
parallel cousin marriage
so daughters would marry their father's
uh son their father's brother's son
which is otherwise quite rare in the
anthropological record
and that would cause a very different
social structure to emerge
so if you just think about different
groups different religious groups as
coming up with
different notions of what they think god
wants and you know
not really random but but a lot of
randomness in that process
uh then you know some groups are that
they might pick traits just by chance
that end up leading to long-term success
and so it's not always fruitful to think
that we can look back into the minds of
the people in the past and
and assume that they saw the wisdom of
what they were doing rather than just
being
you know sometimes you get lucky yeah
and it does uh
there's the bright side of this way of
thinking about it i think
one of the bright sides would be to say
that this might be an example
where you know we're always looking for
explanations in a very materialist way
right you know here is the the reasons
why the conditions would have led to
this no matter what but maybe here
ideas whether the ideas were right or
wrong actually
had a huge influence on how society
developed
yeah and i think that's a really
important idea because i'm certainly
have
much of my work actually looks at how
the economic or ecological conditions
favor this or that cultural practice
but the interesting thing about religion
is that
it you know it forces people to do stuff
or it motivates people to do stuff they
wouldn't otherwise do right do crazy
things that would otherwise seem
not very economically smart and that can
then because of that it can have these
big
knock-on effects because people are sort
of going out of the
of the normal modes that you would
operate and it's also it
it's the parallel with how we think
about natural selection in the
biological realm
uh is very clear when you talk about how
different societies were experimenting
with different ways of doing things and
sort of
whatever the motivation was the western
church hit on
a system that really encouraged
competition
and the free market of whatever both
money and ideas
right right and uh yeah i think uh this
is a really important way of thinking
and it's
it runs a little bit contrary to how
people typically think about social
science and think about things it's
we have a kind of very cognitive heavy
you know individuals doing smart and
sensible things based on their
appraisals of the situation
rather than you know people are sort of
groping around myopically and this was
just one particular path that this pop
these populations started groping their
way down yeah but i mean this is what
how evolution works right it is really
random i mean natural selection works
there's random mutations and the ones
that work will catch on and so in in
some sense
that's uh a way we can think about why
weirdness took over the world
right yep that's exactly and you
you say the western church uh i think
that's the very specific choice because
of course we think of the catholic
church
uh but the protestant churches count
also and in fact i think you try to make
the case that the protestantism
accelerated
this trend the protestants were even
more uh weird friendly than the catholic
church was
yeah and you know one of the things that
i had in my mind when i got started is
you know
famously there's this german sociologist
max weber who had emphasized
the connections between protestants face
protestant beliefs
and the emergence of capitalism and
markets and uh the kind of big economic
expansion you see after protestant as a
metro 1500
and but protestantism is such an
individualistic religion where people
are kind of alone
the only thing that matters is your
mental states so your faith your good
works don't matter
you know the big debate um people work
super hard they're very frugal you know
at least this is the asp you know the
aspiration
the work ethic yeah the work ethic
exactly
but how do you get to a world where that
is a as a
is a kind of religion that can spread
and so i think that the world at least
where protestantism was successful
was already pretty individualistic and
where mental states already mattered a
lot
so this was very much just wrapping the
kinds of intuitions people had from
their psychology
uh wrapping them in sacred garb and you
know kind of making them even more
powerful by doing that
so i mean we talked about reading before
and
to emphasize this point about
protestantism is you know the notion was
that every individual men and women
should learn how to read so they can
read the bible for themselves
and understand it enough to improve
their personal relationship with this
supernatural being
and that's just so arrogant from the
point of view of most religions where
you know why should every person have to
do this you got to be a specialist you
got to be a scholar you got to read some
ancient language
uh but protestant had them you know
we're going to put that we're going to
write the bible in german and we're
going to teach all the girls and
just because women are oppressed at this
period
uh you know we're going to teach them
all to read the bible and you know
they've got to do it too so
female literacy begins spreading with
male literacy it's just a very unusual
uh from the point of view of lots of
other societies it's a very unusual way
to think about things
but you can see why it would catch on i
mean i don't want to uh
i don't want to run ahead of the data
but it seems natural that if the story
is on the right track
then it would nudge us in the directions
of things like
capitalism democracy the scientific
revolution all these things that we
think of as
being fundamentally based in individuals
trying their best to do something and
and
both competing and cooperating with each
other to do it
yeah and and that's kind of my case that
protestantism was a kind of accelerant
on the kind of psychological and
economic processes that were underway
and is there how much do we know i sort
of asked this already but maybe
i can ask it in a different way how much
do we know about the comparative
what was going on a thousand years ago
or 500 years ago
in china or the islamic world i mean
they had very advanced societies
but are you going to say that it's
because they didn't quite
uh catch on to this individualism idea
that uh
europe left ahead a little bit
yeah uh and so you know i make the point
a big point of the book is that you know
europe was a very unlikely place to see
to
to find this you know if you had been in
you know i i have an
alien appearing at the earth from orbit
at one point and
in the year 1000 and you know noticing
all this activity in china and the
middle east
and central asia and places like that
where there's lots of impressive science
being done
and uh impressive monuments being built
and europe seems to be a relative
backwater in the year 1000. and
there's also some muslim scholars who
are making similar observations
and so you know then the question is why
did this happen and
i make the case that it's you know the
change in psychology
initiated by the church and the change
in the social world led to these new
institutions
led to things like representative
government gave a boost to things like
science
and then eventually led to more rapid
innovation
because i make the case for the
collective brain which is this idea that
innovation is driven by
the recombination of ideas so the larger
a population you have and the more
interconnected it is
the more ideas can flow among diverse
minds
and create baby ideas uh and so
you know i have various lines of
evidence in the in this penultimate
chapter
making the case that there's you know
apprentices moving around europe and
masters get taken jobs in different
cities and
just lots of opportunities for different
ideas to be combined more people are
becoming literate
so they're reading books written in the
past or written by someone who lives
very far away
just swapping ideas i mean it resonates
let me be self-indulgent here just for a
second because it resonates with two
previous podcast guests
that i've talked to uh one is jeffrey
west uh who in his book scale tries to
make this
uh case that just getting a bunch of
people together in the same place
talking to each other is a huge
accelerant to new
ideas and that that sounds like it's
part
of your larger story yeah
and so you see urbanization it starts
going up i describe this process where
people are moving from the hinterlands
because they're not tied to their kin
groups anymore and the cities and towns
are
you're both getting new towns where
they're adopting these charters of
rights and privileges for individual
citizens
and you're getting cities growing so
rapid urbanization passing china in
about 1200
probably doesn't pass the kind of circum
mediterranean until after 1500
but just larger cities lots of trade
between the city so ideas flowing
between the cities
for the most part one shared religion uh
so
people can flow universities have
scholars moving from town to town
so just lots of things energizing that
flow of ideas
and at the risk of uh you know stepping
on a third rail here another podcast i
did was with will wilkinson who is a
policy analyst
uh who talks about the polarization
divide in
the united states which he claims is
mostly i would
for many many good very uh empirical
reasons
is mostly an urban rural divide and he
actually
uh relates psychological tests
the big five personality inventory to
the choice to live in an urban area
versus a rural area and again you see
that
people who are open to new ideas are
going to be driven to the urban areas
where things are exciting and not
necessarily comfortable whereas
people who are more traditional but
maybe also more conscientious will be
happier in a
more stable rural environment
right and and within that kind of basic
way of thinking
uh so he's making an argument for self
selection there and
i'm sure that can play an important role
in the us today but of course in the
past
it used to be that 95 of everyone was in
a rural society
so as so a lot of people over the last
few hundred years
you know in general everybody's much
more urbanized
uh so there's been this dramatic change
over centuries in the amounts of
urbanization
and you can i in the book i touch a
little bit on you know the differences
between cities that are on rivers and
are port cities and they tend to be more
cosmopolitan more open to strangers
immigrants of course are a massive boost
to to invention because they bring
fresh new ideas they actually make the
locals the native warrants more
innovative when they when they come in
with from other places i mean you say of
course but there are people who
don't quite perceive this right so it's
of course to me because i've been i've
been actually writing a review of this
evidence
yeah well or of course to anyone who
hangs out in universities you know that
immigration
you know getting getting smart people
from all over the world is the best
thing that we can do
um okay final uh previous podcast guest
i will ask you to
comment on i recently had uh david
savage on who has written a wonderful
history of democracy and um
i i learned a lot from it and if i can
boil his story down to a very
simple idea he he argues that if you go
a thousand years ago and compare europe
to the islamic world
or china the irony is that you know
technology and and state institutions
and bureaucracy were
weaker in europe than they were in the
islamic world or china
uh we just just like you said if an
alien were looking down on the year 1200
uh europe was a backwater and because of
that weakness
the governments were weak the kings
didn't know how many taxes to collect or
have an efficient way to raise an army
and that made it easier for democracy to
develop and then when democracy
developed it made it easier for science
and technology to take off so
that sounds maybe complementary but not
quite the same as the story you're
telling
yeah i mean uh i think it can be
consistent with it
the the interesting thing is though uh
one of my co-authors which i summarize
his work in the book is that an
account like that doesn't explain why
even today
uh you can take uh immigrants say you
take immigrants to europe from around
the world
and you look at the intensive kinship of
where their parents came from so these
are second generation immigrants
you can predict they're at their whether
they vote
their participation in demonstrations
all kinds of things that make
democracies run
based on the the kinship system of where
their parents came from
so there really is a kind of
psychological element in which kinship
alters people's minds in ways that makes
them uh
more willing to do the things or more
interest in doing the things that that
make
make modern democracies run yeah i mean
this is why
this is how we started the conversation
but um
of course psychology is important of
course bureaucracy is important of
course technology is important of course
religion
is important do you ever do you ever
like it you know when you're falling
asleep at night just think oh my
goodness i will never figure this out
there's just too many things going on
yeah yes i mean i do think that um but
i i mean i guess you know part of my i
guess i'm trying to get a big idea on
the table
and and try to convince other people
that it's an interesting idea
which is that so much of social science
so thinking about economics and
psychology
but also other disciplines have assumed
that psychology is something fixed in
humans
and that we can assume that constant and
then they try to figure out the
economics or the institutions or
something like that
now maybe i'm just making the problem
harder because they could i'm saying you
can't assume that's fixed
right that's that's not a parameter now
it's a it's a state variable
and so uh you say you got to measure
more things and it's going to take a
bigger data set and whatnot
to figure it out so um
and then the key idea is that the our
minds actually adapt to the institution
so
you know i i have emphasized this
kinship stuff but that's really just one
part of a much larger story
where things like markets and this
competition among societies and
religion can affect how we think and
what we pay attention to how long our
memories are
um so you know so if you want to tell if
you want to understand psychology you
got to understand history and you
understand history you got to understand
psychology
so i guess i'm trying to encourage a
more interdisciplinary approach to all
these questions
yeah which which i'm very very
sympathetic to it it makes perfect sense
and i guess
the other thing that you know you
already said and i i don't want to get
lost because it's crucially important
and
tracks very well with what david savage
was saying is
the idea of the path dependence of these
developments you know the
it wasn't inevitable from the start
slight difference in choices
uh amplify and branch out and you're not
guaranteed to end up in the same place
yeah yeah i think that's a really
important point um
and it's hard to know exactly how things
are going to play out right so
one of the things that i've suggested in
terms of you know i think that humans
are pretty bad at designing institutions
from the top
down but we do know how to design
variation selection systems
so you can have a bunch of people trying
different ways to make an institution
and then see how they perform over some
you know reasonable period of time
and then kind of take the best so we
should be more of a
have a population thinking a kind of
natural selectionist thinking
in trying to figure out the best
institutions or the best policies to
solve problems
yeah and it's sort of experimental uh uh
trial and error kind of attitude toward
these things yeah yeah i mean even and
so
i sometimes highlight these experiments
where we have we give
put students or something in a simple
simple institution where they have to
solve a public goods problem we have
them pick which one they want to go into
most of the time they pick the wrong one
they don't pick the institution that
maximizes the public good and gives them
the highest
dollar payoff they pick some institution
that allows them to avoid punishment or
has some other thing they like right i
mean you know
yeah life is complicated and it's good
to have a whole bunch of different
people trying out different things so we
can learn from what they do you know
it it makes sense in retrospect okay i
mean maybe to close things out this is
uh you know been a fantastic
conversation and i know again you're
trying to understand what happens in
these societies but
once you talk about these issues it's
almost impossible to
not think about what should happen in
these societies right it's sort of the
more moral uh aspects or normative
aspects of these things you know people
everyone knows that western societies
are individualistic
and you know that's led to great
material prosperity but
it's also led to breaking down of the
tightness of family bonds and things
like that i mean
can we learn about right and wrong and
choices we make for making
a good society from this kind of
analysis as well as just
a society that leads to universities and
psychology classes and experiments
yeah i don't well so the i mean the
problem with the normative question is
you always got to tell me what what is
it you're trying to maximize right
yeah uh so we talked a bit about
innovation
and i feel like i i have things to say
about how to increase innovation and
it's built around the collective brain
and the
free flow of ideas and more trust and
the value of immigrants and so there's a
kind of whole
program of what the what a policy would
look like to try to increase
uh innovation but then you could say you
know if you care about
uh religious homogeneity or uh you know
lots of other kinds of things
right you know then you know you know it
all depends on what you might want to do
yeah i think well i think that's fair
okay good enough
do you have any uh my my final question
is i'd like to end on an optimistic note
on the podcasts uh
you know given what we've learned about
weirdness and the human brain
uh does this give us any insight onto um
how we can be even better at uh forget
if we
forget about choosing right from wrong
on those values that we agree on we want
people to be happy and prosperous and so
forth
uh what are the lessons that we learn
that we can actually put to work making
society a better place
hmm
well um i mean i think that this idea of
create i mean i'll go back to my
innovation point which was that
you know taking the lessons of all this
kind of innovation the more that we
bring
different voices into the conversation
uh and people from diverse backgrounds
uh and have egalitarian conversations
non-hierarchical social structures
the the more we can develop new ideas
and new ways of doing things
so it really is putting together this
large collective brain and you know
that's the kind of hope for solving a
lot of the big problems we face
there are social problems in the sense
that we got to cooperate but if we can
also come up with technological
solutions or institutional solutions
uh that's gonna be really important i
mean i guess yeah one of the points you
made about
uh weirdness is not that it's
anti-social
it's it expands the circle of the people
we can
agree with and work with beyond our kin
and family and clan
to large groups maybe even the world and
that's something that we should
you know joyfully embrace in a time when
the world is kind of in trouble in
various ways
right right so this so you know one of
the things that uh
it the in a weird world what the
there's plenty of social groups but
usually the groups are defined by
what people want to say about themselves
or what they want to cultivate in
themselves
so if you want to cultivate support for
human rights you know then you can join
human rights groups and
get together with other people who are
interested in human rights rather than
the other kinds of groups that one could
join yeah and good lots of good things
we should be doing out there for the
world all right
joe henrik thanks so much for appearing
on the windscape podcast
oh great to be with you thanks
[Music]
you